we're here in the wasps nest or this is
the name the israeli media calls the
jeannine refugee camp it's a place that
has more than 11 000 palestinian
refugees who live in an area that
doesn't exceed one square kilometer 65
of the camps residents are under 24.
we're talking about a population the
majority of which has lived under the
israeli occupation and has never lived
in a place of freedom of statehood
they say that they are fighting the
israeli occupation with guns all
estimates show that there are hundreds
of gunmen in the camp and usually we see
them take up their weapons and fight the
israeli occupation whenever there is a
raid by the israeli army
[Music]
this is the grave of ahmadis
and this is a picture of him next to his
friend
abdullah
when we came here to ahmed's funeral his
friends told us that he lost his will to
live after his friend abdullah was
killed in confrontations with the
israeli forces early in march they're
now buried just meters away from each
other
his friend was telling us that ahmed
lost his appetite for life he felt like
he was helpless hopeless
after the israeli forces killed his
friend he also died while he was
clashing with the israeli forces
and this generation has grew up
listening to stories about
2002 what is known here as the jeannine
battle whereby more than 23 israeli
soldiers were killed 50 palestinians
almost half of them were fighters so
many here tell us that this is the
legacy of the junior refugee camp and
they want to keep that legacy alive
[Music]
you